des poules des œufs ou encore des
fraises du chocolat sous toutes ses
formes Marie se consacre à ses créations
depuis un mois et demi carapac la
demande augmente et si les classiques
sont toujours les plus prisés des
créations un peu plus originales ce sont
glissées dans la vitrine
pour attirer plus de clients toujours
une nouvelle clientèle aussi pour le
regard quand tout ça est en vitrine du
coup les gens sont attirés à rentrer
dans la boutique et cela semble
fonctionner car cette boutique ne
connaît pas la crise ici les
consommateurs sont de vrais amateurs de
chocolat mais la qualité a un coup
il y a trois éléphants
pour limiter les dépenses Brigitte ne
réalise dans ce magasin qu'une partie de
ces achats de Pâques pour les enfants
j'achète plutôt supermarché mais pour
les adultes je j'achète plutôt en
chocolaterie ou en boulangerie parce que
je trouve que c'est une meilleure
qualité
effectivement au supermarché il y a full
pour répondre à la demande un rayon
spécifique a été mis en place la
majorité des produits qu'on fait sur le
saisonnier sont des produits qu'on ne
sait pas le reste de l'année puisque là
c'est des moulages et les moulages on
n'en sait pas tout le reste de l'année
donc c'est vraiment une partie du rayon
à part qui est quasiment inexistante
pleurait de l'année et qu'il a devient
extrêmement importante puisqu'on va
vendre entre 350 et 400 000 euros de
marchandises peu près 100 000 articles
en l'espace de moins de trois semaines
car ce supermarché observe en moyenne
une stabilité des dépenses quand cela
concerne les enfants mais dans les
rayons la vie est plutôt partagée si on
fait attention moi je me fixe 10 euros
voilà un paquet d'oeufs et à un gros
voilà ce qui fait à peu près une dizaine
d'euros au nom on fait plusieurs
on prend ce qu'on voit ce qui est le
mieux
ce qui est sûr c'est que tous les
enfants partiront lundi à la chasse aux
œufs Pâques représente 5% de la
consommation annuelle de chocolat des
Français nous en mangeons 7 kilos par an